last weekend a friend of mine invited me
to a party a birthday party but he had
it in a bar so it was like a tense and I
mean tense never go to a bar party where
you don't really know everybody and you
just show up and it's packed you know
huh it's like it's gonna be fun I got
there's a good yeah it's not fun it's
not fun big awkward tense bar parties
aren't fun it's anxious it's tense cuz
think about it what are you doing it is
going around improvising conversations
hello oh you're looking at him horrible
and it's and it's loud it's loud in
there they got journey blasting and I
know I love journey too but like come on
you could turn it down a little bit
let's get it to a laptop level that's
what I like and you're just talking to
people you're this close you're like
what is it what has that John uh-huh no
dawn sorry dawn I'm sorry Tom you
me Ron Ron yeah that's a great
time happy birthday that's a fun thing
but we've always been told adults have
always been told that parties like that
are fun but they're not actually fun
that's why we drink that's why the
second you get there like I need a drink
now because it's terrible it's not
actually fun that's why you have to
drink if you have 12 gimlets suddenly
it's a better time next thing you know
you're saddling up to a stranger just
like I loved all about
and that's a good thing but I guess I
got into thinking about that listen to
me that that means that's not actually
fun because here's my point there's
stuff that's supposed to be fun and then
there's actual farm an actual fun is the
type of fun you don't have to drink to
enjoy like swimming whoo-hoo swimming
swimming is actual fun romping and
playing splashing that's actually a good
time I have never once jumped off a dock
into a lake and come up with I could
really go for a Manhattan never and you
know who's the best at having actual fun
kids look to the children magic shows
mini-golf pool parties and kids don't
Brown with the pool parties they have
real pool parties go to a kids pool
party not uninvited which one is mine
go to a kids pool party you have reason
to be there every single kid is in the
pool 12 kids go to the party 12 kids get
into the pool 12 wrinkly California
Raisins get out of the pool diving for
rings what is this voice playing Marco
Polo throwing up cuz they're so excited
to swim just like just gonna breathe up
last blow oh I'll give a but go to
an adult pool party not one
in the pool what I've got a pool party
an adult pool party isn't a pool party
at all it's a perimeter party standing
on the outskirts drinking beer trying to
have a good time when they could
actually just jump in the pool and
really have a good time out there beer
sipping beer sipping and chip dipping
stop with the chips and dip and go for a
dip you dip chip
here's the thing
the reason adults drink is because we're
trying to have fun like kids have
naturally because every kid just
naturally acts like they're three drinks
in right look at children are like you
want to eat some paste and dig to China
it's fun but is the belts we need to
make more of an effort to have actual
fun and we don't need booze to do it I
say if you're near a pool jump in die
for rings for sake you're at a
kid's birthday party make sure it's safe
then go in the bouncy house if you're at
a petting zoo pet heavily you don't need
to be drunk to enjoy a baby goat it's a
baby goat that's a good time just get a
handful of that weird gray dry food and
live your life like this little tongue
is tickling my fingers that's actual fun
goats are actual fun